hey everybody this is Jimmy with bright
insight today I'm going to talk with you
about gobekli tepe
bottom line is that this is 100%
definitive proof that not only is the
history of human civilization far older
than what we were taught in school and
what is actively still being taught at
the public schools and universities that
it is also definitive evidence that
there is some sort of lost ancient high
technology or machinery that was
utilized to not only cut and carve these
stones but lift them and place them
where they where they are because when
we're talking weights as high as 40 to
60 tons think about that like how about
you research what year was that we
finally developed a crane that could
lift that type of weight and you have to
ask yourself how could this possibly
have been done 12,000 years ago yes
that's right 12,000 years ago as they
were able to carbon-date from pottery
and other artifacts are located in
around the site now put to put that in
perspective what is currently being
taught in school about ancient Egypt is
that the pyramids are 4,500 years old
now I have another video about that
which you know look there's significant
evidence that you know the ruins around
ancient Egypt are significantly older
than what we've been taught but the
bottom line here is that we have a site
that is twice as old as Stonehenge and
only five percent of it
has been excavated and it's huge it's 50
times bigger than Stonehenge in fact
this is gobekli tepe
is ninety thousand square meters that's
bigger than 12 football fields people
like it's humongous and guess what it's
located in Turkey and just a few years
ago Turkey removed all of their funding
for the excavation and this thing hasn't
been touched in a few years and they're
only 5%
they've only excavated 5% of it as
validated by ground-penetrating radar
like it's absolutely massive I mean you
can see the pictures here of these
t-shaped pillars that range anywhere
from 40 to 60 tons some of the lower
estimates as you'll read on Wikipedia
say 20 times which by the way like if
you're researching and getting your
information from Wikipedia on anything
having to do with ancient technology or
ancient civilization like you really
need to double check now
the sources they list on it because
you'll see huge discrepancies but you
also need to look at information as put
out by leading archaeologists in
geologists about anyways I don't even
get me started on that subject but the
informations out there guys go look for
it it's it's there now what's even more
interesting is that Gobekli Tepe is
aligned with the north-south east-west
equinoxes and it also has alignment with
various constellations in the sky like
it's unbelievable like how did they have
the technology or the knowledge to do
something like that twelve thousand
freaking years ago you know right now in
what's being taught in what we were
taught is that and they hardly even
mentioned this in school too but that's
a whole other story is that so
the Sumerian culture located in
Mesopotamia dates back 6,000 years ago
and that is considered the first you
know human civilization they had the
first writing the first calendar which
we still use today by the way and as
well as like various mathematical
formulas and other things so that's
6,000 years ago so this is twice as old
as that and yet if you look at the
pictures you aren't just how complex
this [ __ ] is it's unbelievable and by
the way the pictures that you're seeing
are mostly of foxes snakes wild boars
cranes wild ducks but they also have
various human extremities that appear on
some of the pillars arms and even show
some with a tail it's really really
interesting stuff but this wasn't
discovered until 1995 gobekli tepe was
discovered by professor schmidt from the
german archaeological Institute and
these t-shaped pillars by the way that
you're looking at are anywhere from
three to six meters tall so in other
words approximately 20 feet at some
point it's like I said this was
discovered 1995 but at some point in the
long path distant past this was buried
it was deliberately buried and you get
in the way they've excavated with the
stones and sand and gravel were
literally dumped into this huge area why
who knows like maybe some was trying to
hide it maybe they were trying to
preserve it there's a million theories
but nobody knows obviously right but
there's over 200 of these pillars of
these t-shaped pillars and they're
absolutely ginormous and when you
consider this is 7,000 years older than
Stonehenge and that it's 90,000 square
metres and that the stone these pillars
are 42
see tons guys the evidence is right in
front of us that they obviously had some
sort of amazing technology that was at
least on par with what we have today or
maybe more advanced we don't know guys
you have to start researching the this
global Cataclysm that there's
overwhelming evidence that happened
11,500 years ago and and another
incident twelve thousand seven hundred
years ago you have to start asking
yourself some questions here this what
we have what we were taught is not
accurate what is currently being taught
to our children and as well as people
the university level is not accurate why
is that why is it that the Turkish
government has prevented any excavations
for the last few years
white guys hello wake up we have the
evidence right in front of us and it's
time that these questions start getting
answered as far as why is the
excavations not currently going on right
anyways this is Jimmy I'm bright insight
be blessed all